i
alternera en surface et en
hauteur et peut-être une
disparition des fameux
caténaires.
- Le REM de l'ouest
n'est pas encore achevé et
pas consensus, mais un autre
est déjà sur.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT
premier ministre du Québece veux
prendre quelques minutes
pour vous en parler,
c'est le REM 2.0.
- Une qui relierait la station ,
au métro Longueuil. Puis i
irait vers l'est, en passant par
le Vieux-Longueuil.
il y a des préoccupations.
- Moi,- Moi,- Moi,- Moi,- Moi, n
au sol plutôt que d'avoir
le train en hautes autres pays,e
fait, pourquoi pas ici au Canada
ou au Québec.
- En tant que résidente,
un train qui passe dans
le Vieil.
- Si c'est des affaires en
hauteur, comme il semble voulois
moins d'accord. Mais je pense
que Catherine va travailler pour
que ça s'intègre.
la mairesse, a même déjà obtenu
des assurances.
CATHERINE FOURNIER
mairesse de Longueuil
sur pied par la Caisse qui va
aire certaines
propositions.
- Longueuil enrien sur une portn
de près de deux kilomètres.
- On a des bonnes discussions
sur ce plan-là pour voir
développer le REM mais au sol,
pour qse être beaucoup
plus harmonieux.
SARAH V. DOYON, directricetoirec
- Ce qu'on doit retenir
du psychodrame du REM de l'est,
en fait, c'est qu'il doit y
collaboration entre les
différentes parttes.
- Et François Legault anticipe
les futures portions aériennesÇT
premie rministre du Québec
- D'abord, si onpossible de peir
en blanc et d'intégrer ces
structures-là, quand elles sont
en hauteur, pour que ça soit
solutions aussi pour ce qui est
- L'ARTM dit ne siéger qu'à un
comité qui n'est pas décise Rése
Transport de Longueuil est
sans nouvelles de la Caisse,
a qui